الى مدينه شرم الشيخ في مصر حيث تتواصلوا
اعمال الجلسه الافتتاحيه لقمه المناخ
السابعه والعشرين بحضور اكثر من 100 وعشره
من قاده وزعماء العالم والمنظمات الدوليه
وقد قال الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
في كلمته خلال الجلسه لافتتاحيه لمؤتمر
قمه المناخ انما يحتاجه العالم للتغلب على
ازمه المناخ يتجاوز الشعارات والكلمات وان
الشعوب تتوقعون قاده العالم خطوات حقيقيه
وما الموسى لفضل الانبعاثتك
انما يحتاجه عالمنا اليوم
تتجوز ازمه المناخ الراهنه
و للوصول الى ما توافقنا عليه
كاهف في اتفاق باريس
يتجاوز مجرد الشعارات والكلمات
عندما تنتظره منها شعوبنا اليوم
والفعال والعادل
تتوقع منا شعوبنا خطوات حقيقيه
سبق انعقاد قمه المناخ في مستر بايام
تقرير للامم المتحده وصف بالمتشائم تقرير
الامم المتحده الذي يحمل اسم تقرير فجوه
الانبعاثات لعام 2022 اوضح ان تعهدات
الدول في مؤتمر جلاسكو بسكتلندا العام
الماضي احدثت فرقا ضئيلا في الانبعاثات
المتوقعه لعام 2030
سيؤدي الى خفض الارتفاع الى ما بين درجتين
واربعه اجزاء الدرجه المئويه ودرجتين وسته
اجزاء من الدرجه المئويه بحلول بحلول
نهايه القرن حين ان السياسات المعمول بها
حاليا تشير الى ارتفاع درجه الحراره
بمقدار درجتين وثمانيه اجزاء الدرجه
المئويه في حلول نهايه القرن واستنادا
للتقرير فان العالم ما يزال بعيدا عن
تحقيق هدف اتفاق باريس للمناخ عام 2015
والمتمثل لحد من ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري
الى اقل من درجتين مئويتين